one of the shortest chess victories ever
achieved in a world championship dingler
in was the first to shock his opponent
as on move four he played the nearly
unheard of H3 whoa what
this is crazy in a position played
nearly a hundred thousand times in the
chess.com database H3 has been played
zero times while ding's combative
Innovation worked well enough it was a
second combative decision with Knight
takes F6 check that led to trouble nepo
recaptured with his pawn and opened the
g-file readying a ferocious attack
pointed directly at ding's King you
can't play around if you're white
because these threats against whites
King can come really really quickly nine
moves later nepo played a brilliant move
Rook takes G5 collapsing the center nepo
converted his attack into a winning pass
sea Pawn which could no longer be
prevented from promoting on move 29 with
less than a minute on the clock a
dejected ding resigned this disastrous
game pending nepo